je me suis baladé pendant plus de quatre
ans aux quatre coins des océans est en
fait comment tout ça at il commencé à 5
argent
j'ai réalisé que j'avais eu peur énorme
boulot et ils peur des requins est en
fait il ya un peu moins longtemps il ya
trois ans après deux ans d'aventuré je
me retrouvais avec ça pourquoi j'avais
accepté
on était dans le cas van go et on était
là pour rencontrer les hippopotames et
les crocodiles
et en fait j'avais accepté l'invitation
d'un ami un peu à contre coeur parce que
j'avais un mauvais pressentiment par
rapport à cette aventure est le deuxième
jour de l' aventure donc voilà le
premier jour je tombe nez à nez
j'avais un peu anticipé ces mouvements
jeu j'arrive je plonge tête première
pour arriver nez à nez avec ce crocodile
et je fais cette photo
le soir au coin du feu on est dans un
camp de base dans le delta je montre
j'aime à l'heure de montrer cette photo
quatre autres photographe sud africain
qui tirent tous la tête parce qu'ils
avaient soit une patte arrière à mort
sauf que un morceau de pet
parce que le crocodile essayer chaque
fois de nous éviter et il se déplaçait
rapidement dans l'eau donc j'avais fait
une photo qui nous verrons l'an demain
va être un des facteurs aggravants d'une
situation dont lendemain matin à 7
heures du matin les autres photographes
19 ans en a pas tant de petits déjeuners
on doit y aller les crocodiles nous
attend tous remontés comme des coucous
en disant on veut une bonne photo de
crocodile et donc on part on croise un
premier crocodile de
3 mettre un petit crocodile et on voit
ce crocodile qui essaient directement de
nous échapper dont ils se mettent à
l'eau je me mets pas l'eau et puis trois
heures plus tard on arrive à
l'embranchement d'un tout petit canal
qui devait faire à peine trois mètres de
large et de la rivière donc vraiment
parallèle le canal fait comme un arc par
rapport à la rivière et l'arrivée est
fait trois mètres cinquante quatre
mètres de profondeur une dizaine de
mètres de large et on voit une bête
immense on voit son dos on le voit pas
ce qu'il est dans moins de deux mètres
de haut et dont on voit un animal qui
doit faire au moins cinq mètres et voit
à peu près cette largeur là c'est
vraiment un animal assez puissant et
donc peut-être dans le courant pour
éventuellement avoir des signaux de pro
à l'éventuelle et donc le l'opérateur
donc la personne qui nous emmène nous
dit bon je vais vous déposez en amont
vous mettez à l'eau comme vous voulez
dont aucune consigne de sécurité je
trouve ça quand même un peu bizarre et
donc moi je choisis de prendre de mettre
dans ce qui ne semble être le plus sûr
donc je mets dans la rivière parce qu'au
moins je dis que si je croise le
crocodile il a le moyen de s'échapper
trois plongeurs entre par le canal est
donc je suis avec le 5e le quatrième
photographes on est tous les deux dans
le dans la rivière je suis prêt le
premier jeu malo et je commence à
avancer j'ai visibilité à peu près
jusqu'à la première rangée donc 3 4
mètres devisy confortable et on se
laisse porter par le courant
puis tout d'un coup je vois plus rien du
tout je voyais plus ma main quand je la
mettais devant le masque j'avais juste
la possibilité à tâtons de sentir la
berge sur ma main droite
donc j'ai vraiment une une sensation
mais instantanée de
la sécurité tout mon corps qui me dit
que vraiment là je suis en train de
prendre des risques énormes
donc je fais surface je pose mon caisson
sur le petit banc de sable qui nous
séparent du petit canal et quelques
secondes plus tard j'ai enfin
l'explication pourquoi je voulais plus
rien c'est en fait l'autre plongeur qui
avait palmer pour me rattraper
il avait soulevé la vase est en fait ni
lui ni moi ne voyons plus rien et dont
le mien était arrivé et comme j'étais
déjà posée sur le bord il y avait un peu
moins de deux vastes donc il a vu et en
fait il ne dit mot vu un sit in en de
bloody croit caudal est en fait j'avais
le genou gauche je croyais m'appuyer à
la berge est en fait j'avais le genou
gauche juste devant la patte arrière
droite du crocodile est évidemment lui
et l'ivi tremblant donc on on se dira
tous les deux le long de la berge sous
réserve et on qu'on se remet de trois
mètres d'écart entre le crocodile et
nous et dans une niveau de stress élevé
je décide d'attendre parce qu'évidemment
on est là pour faire des photos mais il
ya une part de moi qui me dit normand tu
n'es plus du tout à ta place
donc je décide d'attendre un tout petit
peu de regarder si je vois quelque chose
ou pas et puis de traverser la rivière
et finalement après quelques secondes je
décide de traverser l'arrivée donc je me
rêve mais rj mais un mètres sous la
surface je commence à faire 3 4 mètres
et j'arrive je reprends un peu d parce
que j'avais même pas pris monde et en
deux et j'entends rigole alain rigole
alain et je me retournais à quoi 4,5 m
de moins je vois mon ami qui m'avait
et dans cette aventure en train de
voltige et le bras dans la gueule du
crocodile et le et donc à partir de là
un autre ami sud africain et qui juste à
côté s'est jeté sur lui
donc là il la preuve de courage et
absolument indéniable s'est jeté sur lui
au risque de mettre sa vie en danger et
l'a aidé à respirer chaque fois que le
crocodile lui permettait de ramener à
peu vers la surface et lui a sauvé la
vie
donc je la fais courte en quelques
minutes nous avons pu le sortir
alain delot parce que bateau est arrivé
nous avons donné des coups de gaffes
sous maillot du crocodile pour qu'ils le
lâchent
il l'a heureusement lâcher et puis tout
le monde est sorti de l'eau a commencé
un parcours du combattant qui a duré 11
heures pour la mener pour trouver
finalement un hélicoptère un avion
l'amener à johannesbourg au milpark
hospital donc deux ans et demi plus tard
alain aujourd'hui à retrouver un peu
l'usagé de sa main
il a subi 15 opérations des grèves en
tout genre etc
il faut savoir qu'il est né sans main
gauche avec une malformation congénitale
donc vous voyez dans je voulais en fait
commencé par là pour dix mais comment
peut-on en arriver là a fait quelque
chose d'aussi stupide dans la mesure où
on a un prix
quinze jours après l'accident on a
appris par le spécialiste des crocos
d'okavango qu'on n'aurait jamais dû être
là c'était la période de reproduction
des crocodiles et donc la température de
l'eau avait recommencé à monter et donc
l'activité des crocodiles étaient déjà
extrêmement élevé comment arriver là et
bien tout simplement ya six ans j'ai
décidé de dépasser ma peur de l'eau je
sais ça peut paraître un peu stupide
j'avais peur de l'eau et donc cette peur
de l'eau j'ai commencé à me confronter
je gérais un projet immobilier
haibi sein qui était un projet de
développement durable et puis donc j'ai
commencé l'hiver un ag et puis petit à
petit je me suis rendu compte que nager
j'étais jamais à l'aise quand j'étais en
mai donc je me suis acheté un masque
palmes et tuba envoyant j'avais déjà un
petit peu plus de confort et puis je me
suis rendu compte que ce qui
m'inquiétait du jour c'est ce qui est en
dessous donc j'ai commencé la plongée et
gants j'ai plongé je me retournais pour
moi ça veut pas un requin qui arrivait
derrière moi ibiza vous imaginez donc le
saas et le début de cette histoire
avant j'ai une vie d'homme d'affaires où
je côtoyais les requins en
costard-cravate donc c'était une autre
espèce probablement beaucoup plus
dangereuse et donc il ya maintenant cinq
ans j'ai rencontré mon premier requins
et en une rencontre
je me suis rendu compte d'une chose
c'est qu'en fait vous connaissez les
mécanismes de la peur en fait on se dit
qu'on a peur d'une chose est en fait il
ya deux types de peur une peur qui est
fondée parce qu'un jour vous êtes brûler
parce qu'un jour vous vous êtes fait mal
donc c'est une mémoire cellulaire
vous avez accumulé dans votre mémoire
cellulaire un souvenir douloureux ou
difficile donc ça c'est une peur qui est
vraiment inscrite au plus profond de
vous même lorsque vous êtes face à une
situation
votre cerveau se dit tiens est ce que je
suis dans un monde connu ou inconnu vous
êtes dans une situation votre votre
cerveau ne reconnaît pas il va envoyer à
votre corps des signaux votre corps va
dire attention je suis dans une monde
inconnu je suis à la limite de mon de
mazen de confort là vous avez deux choix
le premier set dit ok je ne connais pas
je faire marche arrière
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce cas là
vous allez renforcer ce même signal d'un
confort et votre peur la deuxième
alternative c'est dire ok je ne connais
pas mais qu'est ce qui se passe si je
vais voir un peu plus loin si je pousse
un petit peu cette limite je soulève le
voile et je veux voir est en fête
ce qui se passe à ce moment là c'est
petit à petit chaque expérience l'une
après l'autre sans pour autant prendre
un quelconque risque au niveau de votre
intégrité physique
vous allez créer au niveau de ronald
d'abord un fil
et puis petit à petit vous allez créer
un sentier et puis vous allez créer un
chemin et puis une véritable autoroute
neuronale et la grâce à cette
connaissance accumulée
vous allez augmenter votre zone de
confort et vous allez pouvoir gérer des
situations qui était d'abord perse est
perçu comme étant extrêmement
dangereuses et vous rendre compte qu'en
fait cette notion de danger elle est
toute relative dont une invitation déjà
aller voir derrière vos peurs donc après
cette aventure de pavant je n'ai pas
deux voilà donc comment arriver là on
l'a vu des prises de risque donc la
jeunesse je vous en ai parlé et donc
toute cette dont je me dis voilà
maintenant où on en est après quatre ans
et je vais vous montrer quelques
exemples parce qu'en fait quand vous
êtes dans une aventure comme celle là on
va pas du jour au lendemain fait ce que
vous voyez là stadiers vous confronter
un grand blanc à les caresser un grand
blanc
quand vous faites une aventure il ya un
élément déterminant c'est un
l'apprentissage donc avoir une
préparation pendant cette période de
préparation vous adresser aux meilleurs
spécialistes possible parce que ça me
permet déjà d'augmenter votre
connaissance
parce qu'en fait quand votre ignorance
et grant votre risque est grand parce
que vous ne vous n'avez aucune idée du
milieu dans lequel vous entrez donc tout
va vous paraître a connu une relation
sociale et vous ferez très attention
avec ceux où vous ne pouvez pas établir
de rapport social c'est ce qu'on va voir
maintenant
donc on a parlé de la préparation
apprentissage progressif comment
commence à travailler que d aucuns ben
voilà on est agenouillé on a un des
bords de loire un bâton et les requins
viennent vous dire bonjour
normalement ils sont censés devant roux
loin devant route temps en temps il y en
a un qui arrive par derrière sans
prévenir donc ça ça fait partie des
impondérables le niveau de risque par
rapport à votre ignorance du milieu
anglais en a déjà parlé tout à l'heure
voilà quelques exemples de situations
qui auraient très très qui aurait très
bien pu mal tourner si on n'avait pas
été compétent si on est poli la
connaissance des comportements avoir été
avoir une bonne lecture du comportement
des animaux
les deux photos qui suivent maintenant
il ya en tout et pour tout il doit y
avoir moins d'une demi seconde d'écart
entre les deux photos je travaille qu
une apnée sud africaine un livre i saw
voyez on est au milieu de requins abordé
en afrique du sud et sur le bateau j'ai
un capitaine extrêmement sympa andré qui
a entendu le briefing que j'ai fait avec
un ami en disant voilà je voudrais que
tu arrive comme ça essayer de prendre un
moment où il ya un flux parallèle à moi
au niveau des requins et tu essaies jour
est de faire participer comme si tu
étais un d'entre eux est en fait cette
ce capitaine n'a rien trouvé de mieux
que de jeter des sardines sur mes
épaules en disant je vais d jean-marie à
voir ce qu'il veut
et voilà ce qui se passe vous voyez on
voit toujours ça c'est ce qui reste de
la perspective d'aller donc j'ai
continué à photographier mais regardez
donc je suis j'ai un mur j'ai les
requins qui viennent autour de moi
j'entends les claquements démarche m'a
vraiment partout autour de moi ça c'est
vraiment une situation heureusement la
seule chose que j'ai fait j'ai vidé mes
poumons pour me laisser couler pour
dépasser la zone à risques est entré
dans une zone je me sentais plus à
l'aise
donc ça c'est aussi une expérience un
petit peu inattendu évidemment pas ce
que je pourrais jamais imaginé qu'ils
fassent une chose pareille mais là où on
prend des risques et c'est seulement ma
connaissance et montcalm akiyo au fil
des plongées des années de de travail
que les requins qui m'ont permis de
gérer ça convenablement
autre situation cette longue même
plongeurs tout allait donc très très
grande expérience avec les requins il
pose la main vers l'oeil du requin vais
de l'avant du requin normalement leurs
cases des tout naturellement parce que
il est gêné au niveau de son regard et
si vous faites ça à cheval ou un animal
il va d'office tourné la tête de l'autre
côté à part ceux auxquels elle l'entend
pas de cette oreille là et qu'est-ce qui
fait il provoque une attaque
il se dit non je ne vais pas me laisser
détourner et il vient pour un limite a
dit me dénoncer un requinquer
territoriale et vous allez voir comment
le plongeur gère parce qu'il a une
connaissance parfaite de l'animal aucun
effort il utilise le bout des doigts
sous le la tête du nez du requin et il
utilise les forts du requin pour
déplacer le requin latéralement donc ils
se poussent à l'écart du requin donc
pour vous montrer que même avec un
requin extrêmement agressif c'est un
requin blanc tu 3 3 mètres 50 mal pour
cent il ya moyen de jade et d'envoyer le
ca
le délit salle de circle et on va
terminer par une autre expérience état
psychique état physique
j'ai commis c'est probablement l'erreur
la plus magistrale que j'ai tenu que
j'ai commise en quatre ans de travail et
révéler des prédateurs voilà une femelle
de entre cadres mais très calme et 50
elle n'a jamais vu l'homme ça se voit
son comportement donc elle est beaucoup
plus incisifs et ce jour là on apprendra
on avait peut-être de thon frais il est
là et donc est beaucoup de fluides
corporels et donc nous avions une n'a
pas de choix
si ce n'est qu'en fait c'est un appart
choix oui mais c'est extrêmement
stimulant pour le pour le requin et ça
veut dire qu'est ce qui s'est passé le
requin a dégagé un congénère en nageant
en parallèle ensuite il a dégagé les
trois plongeurs qui étaient à
l'extérieur vous le voyez ici en
s'attaquant pour plus faible des trois
celui ci qui venait d'avoir un bébé donc
ils étaient plus nerveux que d'habitude
il avait quelque chose à perdre
et puis moi je mets j'étais malade donc
j'avais de la fièvre c'est là en fait de
facteurs aggravants
c'est que j'étais agenouillé sur la
cache et j'attendais pour faire les
photos quand cette femelle je devais
prendre la fête de tous alors vous allez
voir elle vient pour prendre la tête de
ton et puis elle me voit elle est
capable de sentir le fait que je ne suis
pas bien
et en fait un prédateur y dégage il
élimine les plus faibles et en fait ce
jour là j'ai pas respecté mon ressenti
pas respecté mes limites et donc qu'est
ce qui s'est passé voilà et les montées
et j'ai une confrontation directe qui a
failli mal se terminer
conclusion je crois que le temps imparti
est déjà passé partez à l'aventuré oui
préparez vous convenablement fait appel
aux meilleurs professionnels ou aux gens
qui ont beaucoup d'expérience pour déjà
évité les erreurs de débutant ne mettez
pas votre intégrité physique et votre
vie en danger
quel que soit le résultat vous voulez
obtenir une dernière chose
l'histoire des photographes attention à
la concurrence
on commence à avoir des rapports d'ego
et c'est la pire des choses c'est
vraiment un facteur où on laisse de côté
son jugement pour aller chercher les
meilleures photos et c'est la dernière
des choses à faire
donc bonne chance dans vos aventures et
j'espère vous ne prendrez pas autant de
risques que ceux que j'ai pris de le
contredire
merci